Hello Freak bitches.
I mean this,
this process of biofeedback was discovered in the late sixties on cat cats in a
tourist Lee,
bad instruction followers,
right fuckers,
right?
So you're never going to,
this is not a cognitive process.
Cats didn't try to make it.
In this case,
cat's got a dropper of milk whenever their brainwaves it up in one direction.
Milk came out a dropper and they learned over time to produce more of this
brainwave that gave them the milk dropper.
Oh,
fascinate.
And then six months of this,
this one experiment that a,
a Dr. Barry Sterman did in the late sixties,
six months later,
he pulled a bunch of cats out of his subject pool to do a,
a rocket fuel exposure experiment.
NASA had said,
hey,
look,
our astronauts are getting really sick.
They're getting nauseous.
How dangerous is this?
You know,
hydrazine stuff we're using as rocket fuel.
Could you please expose a bunch of animals to it and see,
you know,
how much it takes to kill them,
um,
or,
or what the dose response curve is.
And so doctor Sterman at Ucla in the late sixties,
um,
it was exposing cats to increasing levels of rocket fuel vapors and found that
little bit,
you know,
they planted a little more,
they stumbled a little more,
they cried.
And then like seizure,
coma,
death,
this nice linear,
you know,
with increasing dose except of the cats,
he was using a certain subset,
like six of 30 or something,
refuse to have seizures.
And the whole curve of unstable brain was pushed to the right.
Couldn't figure out why until he realized,
oh,
wait a minute.
I use these same six cats in a previous experiment to increase their brainwaves
in this one brainwave that,
that I thought was a nice target to go after.
It turns out that brainwave is the anti seizure brainwave.
When you train it up,
you have decreased dramatically decreased seizure activity in the brain.
And so he found this,
you know,
this brainwave was sort of Metta stable,
eh,
in,
in encouraging brain activity.
And His lab manager at the time was a medication,
uncontrolled,
epileptic,
having like tens of seizures a month,
which is basically a death sentence.
Your brain will,
you know,
Swiss cheese over time and you'll,
you'll have major,
major longterm problems.
Um,
and she demanded,
he built her a biofeedback machine to train up this brainwave.
And over the next year or two they did some training and after a couple of years
she went off all meds.
I'm a seizure free.
Wow,
that's crazy.
And about that time Barry Sterman is funding was all pulled.
Really.
He probably,
he submitted a paper to Epilepsia the journal and suddenly his uh,
government funding all vanished.
So the conspiracy theorist,
uh,
you know,
ideas start to mount.
When you think about,
you know,
the late sixties and big drug companies not wanting a non drug intervention for
epilepsy out there,
there are pockets are loaded with so much fucking doe and they have been so
conditioned by a game that dehumanizes people to the point where they no longer
see giant swaths of humans and other countries as people.
The,
it is important to realize that these wolves that you're talking about,
we're talking about a different species here,
friend.
If you look at like what's going on in the UK with these organized pedophile
rings,
it seemed to consist of people in the highest level of government.
I can't remember who it was.
One of the investigators said,
it seems to be built into the system in some way.
Yeah,
look it up.
It's scary fucking shit man.
That's insane.
So when you look ahead,
avoided that stuff cause it bumped me out when I saw those,
those stores.
But that's what they're saying.
That's what they're saying.
But here's the difference.
Here's the difference.
And that's horrifying to imagine cause you know this,
we hear it.
It's so funny to hear with the UK government and people are like,
what?
But now you hear about a priest doing it and people are like,
yeah,
that just happens.
It's like you're looking at an,
you know,
an organized system that has as part of the destructive,
a result that it reaps on the planet.
Also psychically wounding children in the worst way possible.
So this is a,
uh,
I think that that the,
the reason that that isn't as grim and horrible as it sounds is cause the
difference today as opposed to 30 years ago is that we get to say it in front of
however many zillions of people listen to your podcast and it,
that info instantly travels around the world 30 years ago.
If you think that if there truly is an organized group of pedophiles that have
as their membership,
high ranking government officials,
not just probably in the UK but in the United States too,
if that really does exist,
it didn't just start today or last week or two years ago.
That's been around for a long,
long time.
So the difference between back then and now is that shit is getting everywhere.
It's everyone on planet earth is aware of this investigation.
You can't get that genie back in the bottle.
Even though I think a lot of people are trying,
they're saying that the whistle blowers for for this,
uh,
are not going to have immunity.
That's one thing that the government,
instead,
if you're a whistle blower for this weird ring of pedophiles,
no immunity,
you're going to jail too.
So they're like squelching.
There seems to be an element that is trying to push this shit down of course,
because if it's true that there that some speculate that even members of the
royal family could be involved in this shit.
So yeah,
look it up.
I usually,
it's a deep dark David Lynch level twin peaks shit coaster.
But the,
the,
that might be one of the best descriptions ever.
Say that again.
A deep dark David Lynch level shit goes to
twin peaks style worms deep in the ground.
This is,
but,
but the positive thing is they're getting exposed.
What do you think about us tie steel cups for grappling competition?
So they're not sure they're getting outlawed and a lot of grappling competitions
because they that extra leverage,
they're like a fulcrum point.
Like a leverage point.
Okay,
Lynn,
then everybody's got a free ball,
three ball and you just gotta use that third hook wrap your Dyngus around there.
And I'm saying you see him,
we bring Brian on these podcasts or wouldn't goes in the fucking,
well,
here's the,
here's the thing,
here's the no,
I mean I'm here.
I'm barely 11 and a half,
so I wouldn't have,
I don't,
I usually don't train with a cup.
You don't know because my legs are so big that it's,
it rubs with bruising in the,
in the inside of my thighs.
I personally,
I have a thing I like to call it combat cock where everything just pulls in sin.
Yeah.
Do you remember those guys knows better than to get fucking hanging out there.
Hey,
how you doing?
What's up high five with your blood's educated.
My Dick is smart.
Just like the Shaolin Monks.
I've known guys who have lost a ball from that.
Yeah.
Not me.
Well there's Brian Foster's.
I was,
it was,
it was my foster.
UFC isn't training and he got kicked in the balls and last one.
It was balls.
Yeah.
Did you ever find it just to
make terrible decisions?
What's going on?
His Dick is always like,
what are you doing?
Where is Dick as Ben?
Can you imagine if Dick's lucky to be alive?
Yes,
I have it.
I've seen like pictures.
Oh,
you've been in the room,
you know,
like you after it's over,
you just want to take like a whole,
like a bottle of paint than her and be like,
you need to just dip in this real quick.
Okay.